other than lynn because we know he has a
wonderful influence on this whole show
is there any member of the cast that
just really
surprised you whether it was what they
did with their role when they were on
stage or maybe even just how they
carried themselves amongst the team
oh man i mean that's we're talking about
my family now
these are these are and that's i mean
it's not even an exaggeration you know
living through that first year on
broadway and with that show
and like everything that happened and
the people that came to see the show and
the opportunities that
we were given you know meeting the
obamas on multiple occasions
and meeting prince and you know it's
just like
it is insane and i think we we went
through the trenches together because
like as
as as amazing as it was and what it felt
like it was on the outside it was also
at the end of the day we were doing
eight shows a week of
really really grueling stuff physically
like the ensemble were on stage the
entire
i mean you've seen it we don't leave the
stage we're moving furniture we're we're
we're swirling guns we're doing a
bazillion costume changes we're
singing backup vocals it's just it is
non-stop and it's exhausting and
and a lot of our days off were were
taken away for these unbelievable
opportunities that we were given and we
were all
really tired but um but knew that it
just was we were
this thing was something so special and
and so different and and
and was kind of turning into this
phenomenon like right in front of our
eyes but i definitely think we were
living in a moment where we felt like
the cart had
very much gotten away from the horse
like we just were like this runaway
train and we were just trying to like
keep up with it
um and and it was just an experience
that none of us have ever
none of us have ever or and might not
ever experience again
it just is it's insane and i think um
it's it's really hard i mean you know
jonathan groff is a really good friend
of mine the couple moments that i had
off stage like his dressing room was
like right in the wings
and so we we like actually spent a lot
of time together during the show and got
really really close and he's just like i
mean
i think everybody already knows this but
he's just like a dream of a human
um and i just i just respect him so much
and and adore him so much i'm so
grateful for his friendship and i think
um you know and and i think jasmine
cephas jones has become
one of my closest friends and sisters
truly and she's just
such such an unbelievable artist and you
know her and anthony are dating and so
like
we spend a lot of time together and
anthony is just like my little brother
who i
i just who makes me laugh endlessly and
i just think what all of them and
and i think leslie leslie odom jr the
stillness
that he brought to burr and the like
profound
depth that he brought to that role um
and watching him do that every night
um was j and with and every night it was
fully committed no matter what was going
on
it and he was so present and and you
know he was just
such a such a voice for
for this family um of actors
and and you know he put he put himself
on the front lines for some stuff
um and and and and to fight for us
and for things that we needed and and
and i just i adore him for that because
he didn't have to do that and i think
um i have some of the best relationships
in my life
i have from that show and and every i
mean it's hard for me to pick
you know it's it's like i talk to them
every day i talk to someone from that
show
every single day and we are all so close
and renee
is unbelievable and and it's it's
it's hard how can i it's like asking for
you to take your favorite
like child i don't know
because i already know how special all
of them are just like as
as talents and you can kind of tell over
the years the kind of family you guys
created
um do you want to go back to what you
just said about leslie though because
when
as an outsider when i look at a
production like hamilton the biggest of
the big i imagine you guys get
everything you needed so can you give us
an example of something we had to fight
for
yeah well you know i think it's it's um
it is it is essentially
it is exactly that like the the cart
getting in front of the horse i think it
just was the show
was so much harder than all of us
thought and and and took
so much um so much more physically
from us than than we thought and and and
time wise and
i'm in no way complaining by any means
but just you know
it's like yes we went to the white house
and and and got to
got to meet the obamas and perform for
them which is like i
still is one of the best days of my life
like i have goosebumps on my legs every
time i think about it it's just like
that
i will never forget that for the rest of
my life but you know what
what happened for that to happen was
that we had a full h a week
we traveled on a sunday night to the
white house on our date mondays are
the day off on broadway so that and then
we were at the white house and performed
at the white house and were like
doing like things and activities and
and and performances at the white house
all day monday
we left the white house at you know 10
p.m got on the bus
drove through the night back to new york
and went straight back into another ho
week so it was like
we didn't have a day off but also you're
like giving out so much energy on your
day off because you're meeting these
freaking obamas
you know what i mean it's just like so
it it was like in moments like that that
i think you know
just you know needing needing physical
therapy
and needing needing needing like you
know
um to be taken care of physically to to
continue to do this thing that
we all wanted to do and all believed in
and and worked really hard for but it's
taxing it it takes a toll because our
bodies are our livelihood like
physically
and you know especially for broadway
actors it's it's eight shows a week
is the hardest thing i've ever done in
my entire life
um and it's it is it is
broadway performers are athletes they
are warriors
they are they are they are obviously
artists
but it takes so much to to for an
audience member to sit in a seat and
watch a show
as if it's happening for the first time
it takes a lot it takes a lot and i
think
you know i think it's just hamilton was
asking for a lot
and then more because because of the
grammys and because of
the tonys and because of you know all of
the
the the politicians that were coming and
because of all the special performances
that were happening you know like
there was so many performances happening
not just on the stage at 8 pm at night
there was like so much other stuff going
on
recording the album you know we're we're
having on our day off we're going into
the studio and singing through the show
over and over and over and over and over
again and then going to do the show at
night you know what i mean so it's just
like there's a lot it takes a lot to
to be to be a broadway broadway
performer and it's not for the faint of
heart and i think
you know i think it just it was a show
that demanded more of its actors and
more of its performers and so i think
leslie was the first person to go to bat
to ask for that from our producers and
from the creatives like hey
we love doing the show but we need your
help in supporting us so that we can
take care of ourselves to do
this show that we love and do it well
and do it on the level that
the show deserves and the level that we
want to do it at and a level that of
that is a performance that is healthy
for us so that
you know people aren't getting injured
because people are getting injured a lot
it's a
hard hard show that ensemble
is it looks like it is a walk in the
park and that is exactly why they're
athletes and exactly why they're
professionals and why exactly why
they are the stars that they are but
believe me there is nothing
easy about being in the ensemble of
hamilton there is nothing easy about it
[Music]
you